what's going on everyone i've got a
special presentation for you guys today
this has been on my mind for
um probably about half a week now um
and it's gonna be about money all right
everybody's favorite topic
um and it's probably not gonna be what
you think it's gonna be but it's gonna
be really good
promise so um one of the things that's
top of mind is that i get a lot of
conversations from entrepreneurs who are
like i just want to be in the top one
percent i wanna
and the thing is is the people who are
in the top one percent
live a different way and they also don't
live now the way they did
to get here all right and so i'll tell
you a quick story and then i'm going to
show you what i mean with this
beautiful pyramid and if you're
listening then i'll try and explain it
visually
or audio wise so when i was um
very early on in my career um or earlier
than now right uh i was
showing up to a mastermind event that i
had it was the first mastermind event
um i think we had 28 people who were
showing up and all these people were
paying
40 000 a year and i remember
pulling up to our event it was in
albuquerque uh new mexico
and um they were walking into the hotel
as i was pulling up right
i was like nervous and excited and all
that stuff and um
one of the one of the girls monica
guitar um
uh was like as we're getting out of the
car she was like i thought you guys were
supposed to be rich
and she literally said that and i still
remember to this day because it was like
such a moment for me
um i don't even know if she remembers it
but uh we were pulling up in a prius
that had a crack across the windshield
and a dent in the side door
all right and this car was probably a
six thousand dollar car tops
right and the thing is is at that moment
i was a millionaire like i had a million
dollars in cash right
um sitting in my bank account after
taxes and yet i was driving a 6 000
car and so one of the things that i
consistently
see um is people outliving their means
and this is that's not a new message but
for some reason
it still doesn't resonate with people
and so i'm going to level up this
conversation a little bit
because you're like but wait alex i
thought you now have a bentley which i
totally regret by the way but i do have
a bentley
and we have a very nice home the thing
is is
a bentley for me relative to my income
is less than one week's income for me
income and so one of the
important things to understand is the
relative cost
of any of anything that you have and so
i have always used this back of napkin
math to justify
expenses all right and so as a result of
that
i always have lived on less than five
percent once i started making money less
than five percent
of what i made which pretty much meant
that until i was making a million
dollars a year or more i lived on thirty
thousand dollars a year
right which is if you've heard my other
story about once layla and i made our
first hundred thousand dollars
i told her this is awesome that means
that we have three years of living if we
make no more money
all right because we knew that on on on
1500 a month we could live
right decently comfortably and i'll tell
you this
comfort's nice but there's not that much
more enjoyment you get out of like
driving evently versus a normal car now
i'm sure there's car people who are like
whatever but i'll tell you that the
incremental gain that i have in my life
is not worth the money
this is probably the last expensive car
i'll ever have it's also the first
really expensive car that uh
we ever got but what i wanted to do
though um and kind of shift the
conversation is not just talk about you
know
making uh or spending a lot less than
you make because i saw somebody recently
who was one of our clients
um they graduated from the program and
then they went on to start an online
business they were gym owner
um and i saw the expenses that they were
incurring and i was like man
like that worries me you know what i
mean it just it it worries me because i
i see a lack of judgment
um because you don't know how things are
going to change i mean i think if the
last year for anyone can say that
things can change quickly and i want to
have tons of dry powder
tons of reserves to pull on if i need
them and so for me i get more anxiety
by having expenses and so for me to
actually lower my anxieties i lower how
much i spend
and so if that's something that you can
associate for yourself as in the less
money i spend the more relaxed i am
um then i would encourage you do it
because for me it's been one of my kind
of
secret sauces of success is just like
just don't spend a ton of money
especially relative to what you make and
so what i want to do for the rest of
this
is kind of first talk about what it
looks like to get in the top one percent
and then how to get there all right so
right here you've got a pyramid and if
you're listening um then you can
listen along but there's four layers to
this pyramid all right and this is kind
of the top one percent pyramid
the bottom layer of this is people who
have these are considered high net worth
individuals
all right that means you have one to
five million dollars in assets
all right now this may surprise you but
uh
the people at this level and i've got my
notes here so i'm going along with this
um in the united states it's 1 in 69.
so 1 in 69 people is has between one and
five million dollars
so being over a million is not even top
one percent anymore
um i mean it sort of is but like it
technically it's a little like if you
actually had one million dollars you
wouldn't be in the one percent
um but i find that but that's in assets
not income
right that's in assets not income you
don't need to make a million dollars a
year to be in the top one percent
right and what's crazy to me is that the
top one percent income
is 400 000 a year but the top one
percent in assets
is only a million or a million and a
half bucks
how nuts is that it means people spend
all their money
that's what that means so if you have a
top one percent income
you should be way above the top one
percent in assets
but it doesn't work that way because
people always want to show off
and people can't think long term and the
only thing that i've been continually
reading about because i've been
really pouring a lot into really reading
a lot about monger
and um and uh buffett so warren buffett
and charlie munger who
are founders and one of berkshire
hathaway
is how they live and how they think in
terms of long term
and so i'm going to transition to
talking about how to get there but i'm
going to finish this little chart for
you
so this is the top 1.5 percent roughly
of the u.s is one to five million in
assets and that's one in 69
so if you i for me i like the one in
personally it makes it more real for me
so 1 in 69 people all right now in the
us
the next level is very high net worth so
you go
high net worth to very high net worth
individual for this
it's 0.3 percent all right of people
that's crazy now here's what it is in
math that's one in
338. so one in 338 people
is worth between five and thirty million
dollars that's what they have in
investable assets
five and thirty million dollars
i'm i'm purposely putting this out there
to hopefully counter the instagram
culture of
flexing in front of a lamborghini or
bentley right whatever
because most people are broke
like most people are poor and i i think
that i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna lay
out a a a plan for you that's very
simple
to get you above this to really just be
in the top one percent
and the thing is is like i said the top
one percent income earners or
earn over four hundred and twenty
thousand four hundred forty thousand a
year depending on where you're looking
that's per year so for you to get over
five million
like you just need to live on a lot less
than you make if you're in the top one
percent
income earners you should be in this
five to thirty million dollars within
not a ton of time right and then the
the level above that is ultra high net
worth individuals
which is uh one in 13
83 and that's uh what is that that's
point zero seven percent all right point
zero seven percent
all right and then finally i'll just
finish this little chart out
um billionaires is uh one in
468 000 all right
and uh and the percentage there is point
zero zero zero four zeros
three zeros three zeros two percent all
right now the reason that uh the jump
between the the third stage and the
fourth stage is so large is that
the range is between 30 and a billion so
everyone that's between got between 30
and a billion
is in the next level and then
billionaire is the fourth category so
these are kind of like the
the four layers above the one percent
the very first layer kind of gets you
into the top one percent
more or less right and then um above
that you have the varying categories
the thing is is that in order for you to
get to
above five million dollars so not even
top one percent but top point
three percent all right one in three
hundred and thirty eight so you walk
into
the 238 people you're probably the
richest person in the room
all right for you to do that
you got to save like 15 grand a year
for 30 years that's it and that's
assuming just nine percent
returns which is just the stock market i
just put in the s p 500 and don't do
anything with it
right that's not doing crypto that's not
that's not that's not learning how to
like
it's literally just save a
you know 1200 a month and and put it
into the s p and do it every month
that's it if you make four hundred
thousand dollars a year so you're making
thirty five thousand dollars a month
right if you live on five you can put
ten thousand dollars and you'll be at
the
you'll be at the top end of this right
but everyone just spends so much money
and so
i i i just when i see this
it's both incredibly encouraging to me
and also incredibly saddening
it's encouraging to me because i feel
like genuinely everyone can get to the
top one percent which doesn't make math
mathematical sense but it makes it makes
realistic sense and you feel like but
alex
how do i how do i save twelve hundred
dollars a month right
so it's two things it's income and time
right
net income being like minus your
expenses so it means it's
make more money spend less money the
easiest thing most people do is they
just spend too much money
right and i know that sometimes you can
like
it's sometimes apparent depending if you
like follow my instagram or whatever but
like
layla and i think i was asking for her
to give me the numbers from last year
but we live on less than five percent of
what we make
all right and you're like well sure
that's because you make a lot yeah but i
lived on that when i made nothing
right and so i think most people like
you should live on 30 grand 40 grand a
year and the thing is is that you
already know
in your heart that spent making that
spending more of the money is not going
to make you happier
i'll tell you right now it's not and if
the point of spending money is to make
you happier i'm telling you it's not
sure like i have this studio
i can justify it as a business expense
um but
i did this mostly because i enjoy it and
to me from from a percentage of income
it's negligible
right and so i got this fancy setup only
after i had already crossed three of
these levels
right
i'm saying this because it just it
frustrates me because
i really believe anyone can do it i
really do you should have to live on a
lot less than you make
and so anyways to finish this out right
what do you do most times you're going
to have to sell something right either
you're selling someone else's product or
you're selling your own product either
way
i say product i mean product service
whatever right but either one of those
categories
and if you make a hundred thousand
dollars a year a hundred thousand
dollars a year and you live on 30 you
can do this
not only can you get into this quote
bottom level the top one percent
but you can get the top point three
percent right now if part of you is like
well
you know that then what's what's the
point of living
it really depends on on what you value
if like and this is kind of backwards
because it's like the type of person who
wants to have more money wants to spend
the money they have
then i can understand it but then at
that point just
don't yearn for more does that make
sense so like don't be dissatisfied that
you haven't achieved your goal for me
what i'm looking at is like how can i
get into this category by the time i die
and use that to impact humanity like in
a way that's that's meaningful
that's what i'm that's what i'm trying
to do right and so
anyways i told you the prius story to
illustrate a point which was i was a
millionaire and living on less than
three thousand dollars a month
right um i owned my car our rent was
1200 bucks
and layla and i lived on
we bought food at the grocery store you
know what i mean like we went out once a
week like it wasn't
like you can do that and live a normal
life like a comfortable life
and that was when we were making a lot
of money and that's because i always
have a fear
or had a fear that i would i was like
what happens if we stop making money i
don't i just don't want to
lose everything and so i think if you
can be satisfied and decrease your
anxiety or make the amount that you
spend
decrease your anxiety you will be
happier so i'm going to leave you with
this one piece
as a final note on this
which is the simple retirement
calculator all right world's simplest
retirement calculator
so if you
live let's say let's say that you are
currently
uh 30 years old all right so you're
currently 30.
and um you want to retire
all right so let's say you want to
retire soon let's say you want to retire
by the time you're 40. all right crazy
[ __ ] you're going to try and retire
entirely by your 40. okay cool i dig it
so if you're a retired boyfriend i'm
saying retired but realistically you're
going to work because you like working
but let's just say that you won't
you don't want to have to work you want
to work on the stuff you like working on
after you're 40.
cool no problem
the percentage of your income that you
spend is going to be the thing that
dictates how
quickly you can retire not how much you
make
so for example if you make 400 000 a
year like i said
right and you save
10 right
versus making a hundred thousand dollars
a year
and you saving uh let's say eighty
percent
is what you save then what you're what
you
every year you're adding four years of
retirement
because it means that you're spending 20
and saving 80k whoo that's great
that means for every year you're getting
four years back which means
if in 10 years at this point you'd have
40 more years
right once you hit 40 because you had 10
years of stockpiling for each year
right you'd have 40 years of living now
mind you that's assuming it's your
current level and that the money that
you now have saved up at this point
because you should have 800 000 right
and that's assuming that none of the
money you had made any money so it'd
probably be closer to like 1.2
right million by the end of that decade
that's really conservative still maybe
even 2 million
right at that point that this money
isn't even making you money that's just
literally assuming a straight
decrease in how much you spend right
that every year would just go down which
isn't even realistic
right but if you did that then you'd get
there and that's on 100
a year right that's it
on the flip side if you're at this 10
guy then every year he gets one tenth of
a year
right because he's saving 40 it costs
him 400 to do a year which means that
this guy is never really going to be
able to retire
right and he's always going to be
stressed or she's always going to be
stressed
and so i say that only to illustrate one
point which is
you have to spend less than you make
it's sometimes a simple [ __ ] that people
don't want to do
and it means that you can either have
your ego and how you look to everyone
or you can have your ego based on the
freedom that you feel and i know that
the vast majority of people will never
do that
i get messages every day from people who
are like
you know they've been trying for 10
years to make a million dollars a year
rather than
maybe trying to make a hundred thousand
dollars first right
and the thing is is to be in this top
one percent you don't need to make a
million dollars a year
not even close you're not even close you
don't even need to make close to a
million dollars here
to be in the top one percent right if
you just add a little bit of time
you can get in the top one percent just
being reasonable right you can get in
the top point three percent
by also being you know unreasonable
because compared to everyone else
right just because the thing is is most
people
are insane in terms of their irrational
with their behavior and their
expenditures they are stressed about the
amount of money they spend and yet they
are the
they're in complete control of how much
they spend just spend less
and you'll be less stressed so anyways
that is my money money message for
everyone today um
we still continue to less on live on you
know five percent
maybe ten percent of what we make i
don't think we live on ten percent
we live on five percent of what we make
and the thing is is like at that point
if you live on if you live in five
percent or ten percent of what you make
then it means that literally one year
if you as like walk walk with me for a
second
if you live on ten percent of what you
make and your money grows at ten percent
then in one year you could retire
assuming you have a stable income from
the the savings that you had on the
other 90
right figuratively one year 15 months
whatever but you get the idea
right does that make sense for everybody
like if you live on 10 percent of what
you make or you live
like you're like but man that's like
poverty levels it's like
yes but it's poverty levels in your mind
based on your perception
not based on reality of the fact that
you're going to be stockpiling
money that will continue to feed you
forever along you want
right and so the the moral of the story
is
spend less than you make the the greater
you can create that disparity the faster
you can retire or get to a point where
you choose to work on the things that
only you want to work on
right and getting into the top one
percent
is literally a matter of saving a
thousand fifteen hundred bucks a month
and putting in the s p 500
that's about it it's all there i mean
like that's that's it
that's all there is to it and the thing
is is it's
so simple no one will do it
that's okay but you're a smart cookie
and you're gonna do it because um
you think that simple things are usually
the keys to the universe which i
agree with you so keep being awesome
lots of love
and i'll catch you guys on the flip side
bye